like you want me to do a lasso a cow i
could probably lasso a cow hi everyone
i'm martha stewart
and i am hosting with snoop dogg snoop
and martha's very tasty halloween and
now i'm about to answer some of your
burning questions
the last thing i googled was oh
tables for greenhouse growing so anybody
out there who has tables for your
greenhouses four by eights i need 30 of
them if um i like to i'd like to scare
people okay so i went out a couple of
halloweens ago and i went as my car
wreck you just draw scars and little
drops of blood on your face and some guy
laughed and said oh look at you you you
that's a great costume i said what are
you talking about i was in a terrible
accident a couple weeks ago and and his
wife said i told you not to talk to her
she was so embarrassed that he had said
it was a costume because i was such a
wreck my biggest pet peeve
sloppiness
real bad incompetence
very bad
oh i have many hidden talents
many if you want me to do a lasso a cow
i could probably lasso a cow
i've climbed about kilimanjaro i was
supposed to do
mount everest but that got cancelled
last second i guess i'd like to do that
like that three-day trip around the
earth
you know 350 miles up that would be fun
if i could choose who i went with
i might have to
but
it's nice to get invited out to dinner
so you know just keep your mouth shut
um my business venture that gives me the
most joy working maybe working with
snoop dogg on special is like our
halloween special
it's very fun day goes by really fast
you never know what to expect and it's
fun to work with a real pro like snoop
be sure to watch snoop and martha's very
tasty halloween on peacock
[Music]
you